I want to look at a couple clips from a
recent episode of the Stephen Bannon
program Stephen Bannon interviewed a guy
almost as ubiquitous as Cher or Madonna
a guy we know of as pillow
of course I'm talking about my pillow
CEO and founder Mike Lindell Mike
Lindell makes it clear he is willing to
lose everything over the machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines listen to this it is surreal
and Beyond parody at this point
how does that make you feel since you've
had your business destroyed your life
destroyed your employees destroyed
you're not in Walmart you're not
anywhere because of your Crusade about
these machines sir
well Steve it doesn't matter if I if it
takes me to lose everything I want to
save our country
how does that make he was willing to
lose everything
he told me during our interview that
he's in about 30 million dollars so far
to this election nonsense still no proof
from him about any of his claims and by
the way one other funny note about this
interview is about Twitter
Mike Lindell is angry that even though
all sorts of right-wingers and spreaders
of lies about the election have been
unbanned from Twitter since Elon Musk
purchased it he hasn't and he's angry my
my shout out to uh Elon Musk would be
yeah you know if your son should be a
new platform of uh of free speech yeah
um but yet you're gonna carve out the
guys that talk about our election crimes
and our election Integrity
um I don't think a sap priest team I
think it's I I think I would like to do
a shout out to Elon Musk right now hey
check out the evidence I was banned
because uh I was telling the truth and
that's that's uh that's disgusting and
uh to be one of the few people that's
still hang on hang on
they have not they have not reached out
to you and asked you for the evidence
you had and ask you yeah Elon is going
to personally decide whether to unban
pillow after looking at his supposed
evidence which he's never revealed to
anyone ever every time I interview
pillow he tells me he'll send me the
evidence he never does he told me he
would send me pillows he never did one
other funny note on this
after pillow airs his grievances about
not being unbanned Bannon actually says
I don't even want to be on Twitter
because it's funded by the Chinese
Communist party I have no interest in
being on Twitter it would never be on
Twitter because it is financed by the
Chinese Communist party and Elon Musk
got a comfort and prove to people that
it's not Tesla the whole deal stinks to
high heaven yeah it all stinks to Steve
Bannon listen I believe we're coming to
the end of the pillow Arc thankfully in
many ways I still am unsure
is pillow a grifter or is he a victim of
the grift I can't tell I used to ask is
he does he believe the stuff he says or
doesn't he I believe he believes the
stuff he says that seems really clear to
me at this point the next question is is
he one of those perpetuating the scam or
has he simply fallen for it I believe he
believes it either way but I can't tell
whether he is a primary node or a
reactive node let me know what you think
and we'll have all these clips on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below